skurrile wende im erdbeerkuchen gay ja
so sieht es aus aber falls sie jetzt
nicht so genau wissen was wir meinen wir
geben die noch mal ein kleiner rückblick
also mecklenburgs vorpommerns
ministerpräsidentin manuela schwesig
derzeit ja wegen ihrer schule
klimastiftung für russische gas
interessen unter rücktrittsdruck die
hatte zu ihrem achten geburtstag vor ein
paar tagen von ihrem
landwirtschaftsminister till backhaus
einen erdbeerkuchen überreicht bekommen
und zwar einen selbstgemachten wie die
ministerpräsidentin per twitter
mitteilte dort hieß es vielen dank für
die glückwünsche zum geburtstag darüber
habe ich mich wirklich sehr gefreut
vielen dank für den besonderen empfang
im kabinett mit erdbeertorte
selbstgemacht von unserem
landwirtschaftsminister ja aber schauen
sie noch mal genau hinsieht dieser
nahezu perfekte erdbeerkuchen wirklich
selbst gemacht aus von einem politiker
unsere meinung der kuchen sind deutlich
zu professionell außerdem hat wohl ein
so großes backblech kaum jemand zu hause
da ist wohl auch kaum mit einem
haushaltsüblichen ofenpass schnee und
wir von bild haben deswegen natürlich
direkt mal in meck-pomm nachgefragt ob
dieser kuchen jetzt nun selbst gebacken
ist oder eben nicht dort halte schwesig
sprecher andreas timm dann ausdrücklich
im namen der ministerpräsidentin und von
minister backhaus folgendes mit es sei
bereits tradition dass minister backhaus
mit seiner familie zum geburtstag des
ministerpräsidenten oder der präsidentin
einen kuchen backt und diesen zur ersten
kabinettssitzung nach dem geburtstag mit
bringt ja genau also am mittwoch jetzt
die wende der kuchen ist eben doch nicht
selbst gebacken sondern aus der bäckerei
dazu haben wir auch noch ein statement
bekommen in den vergangenen jahren hatte
familie backhaus den kuchen mitunter
auch selbst gebacken dieser eindruck ist
bedauerlicherweise auch bei der übergabe
übergabe in diesem jahr entstanden dabei
kam der küchen aus einer bäckerei es
handelt sich um ein missverständnis dass
der minister bedankte soweit also dass
kuchen geld die ministerin also von
terrier seit tagen und wochen berichten
dass sie endlich mal die wahrheit sagen
soll wie ihre rolle in der schule
klimastiftung für russische gas
interessen wirklich ist liegt jetzt in
aller öffentlichkeit es geht zwar nur um
einen kuchen muss man sagen aber lüge
bleibt lüge und das steht einnahmen ist
drin einfach nicht zu ja und dabei wäre
es ja einfach in diesem fall vor allen
dingen so einfach gewesen die wahrheit
zu sagen einfach nur zu sagen sorry
dieses jahr ist der kuchen nicht selbst
gemacht und keiner hätte darüber
gesprochen gut so ist es normal jetzt
ist das kuchen geld in den brunnen
gefallen und wir haben sie immer gefragt
liebe zuschauerinnen und zuschauer wie
schaut denn jetzt schon echt
selbstgemachter erdbeerkuchen
ja allerdings ist der jetzt auch nicht
wirklich selbst gemacht müssen wir ganz
ehrlich sagen der ist nur selbst
gebracht von unserem lieben kollegen
aber wir schauen mal wie das bei ihnen
zu hause so aussieht hier ralf ohlendorf
zum beispiel hat uns diese schöne torte
geschickt oder unter wild hier schön mit
sahne noch na ich glaube von diese hier
ist von jeanette schmitz sieht auch sehr
hübsch aus muss man sagen ja und hier
sogar mit herzchen von michaela ammann
und sie hat uns übrigens auch noch ein
rezept zum super leicht macht kuchen mit
geschickt das können wir ihnen jetzt
hier nochmal einmal zeigen die zutaten
für den biskuit boden sind drei eier 100
gramm zucker 100 gramm weizenmehl und
ein halber teelöffel backpulver für den
belag drauf wie 500 gramm erdbeeren zwei
bücher schlagsahne 300 gramm frischkäse
zwei päckchen sahne steif und 50 gramm
zucker da ist der zuckerschock dann
tatsächlich vorprogrammiert aber dann
hört sich auf jeden fall relativ lecker
das muss man ja
einfach